so now in this maneuver we're going to
be doing it on a table or your bed and
you have a pillow right here because
this device is gonna go right there so
her head will be supported by the pillow
so let's go ahead and go back down here
and then just put this thing right there
okay lay your head down so I'm just
going to make sure the head is touching
so she can just position it right at the
top of her neck so what's happening is
that she has the head not completely
supported by the massage device but she
is caught by the pillow and she's
getting most of the pressure up
underneath the neck so it's very
comfortable some people like more
pressure and they don't even need the
pillow so they would just remove the
pillow and just put the head there but
it's a lot of pressure there so you want
just to put a pillow right here so I can
support that is that comfortable okay so
that's how she would do the neck thing
and this is what I like doing right
before bed and I'll hold this thing for
two three four minutes and man I am out
cold my wife is like you just go right
to sleep you know so so are you feeling
more relaxed every time I do the demo
you look so relaxed okay good
so it works that's why she always
volunteers for the demonstration yeah
okay so that would that would be how you
would do kind of a lying down with that
massage tool